على كل من القاهره ينضم لنا المحامي
بالنقل مصطفى محمود سيد مصطفى اهلا بك
شكرا تواجدك معنا كيف تم الاستعانه بك
اولا لاخراج المطربه شيرين من المستشفى من
طلب من كذلك تحديدا
همم
الموضوع ابتدا ان هو همم الاستاذ حسام
الشيخ استعن بيه قصديقي يعني عن طريق طلب
ورجاء من حسام حبيب اللي هو طريق الفنانه
وتوجهت للمستشفى في اليوم دوت لان كان في
محاولات قبليها في النيابه وفي المستشفى
نفسها من الاستاذ ياسر عنتوش اللي هو
محامي الفنانه
[موسيقى]
لا طبعا كان في مناشدات وكان في طبعا محضر
موجود في النيابه وكان فيه
طلب نقدمه الاستاذ ياسر للمجلس الاقليمي
الصحه عشان خاطر تعنت المستشفى في عدم
خروج الفنانه
لان طبعا كان في اخطاء كثير في دخولها
وعدم خروجها وبقاء في المستشفى المده دي
كلها يعني طيب استاذ مصطفى ما الذي دفع
عقلي قبول هذه الخطوه خصوصا انه الكل يعرف
انه لشرين عندها محامي هو الاستاذ ياسر
انطوش
هو سعادتك طبعا زي ما قلت حكم كان في
محاوله سابقه في نفس اليوم يعني
وطبعا بقت بالفشل
فلما انا طبعا درست الكلام اللي هم
قالهولي والمده اللي هي كانت موجوده فيها
الفنانه
فطبعا حضرتك احنا عندنا قانون اللي هو 71
لسنه 2009 ده اللي بينظم دخول المريض
المستشفى سواء ارادي او او الزام فطبعا
المده ما بتقعدش الكلام ده كله مش موجود
في القانون لان لها مده فتره زمنيه
وبيتبلغ المجلس الاقليمي للسياحه النفسيه
عشان خاطر بقاءها او عدم بقائها في
المستشفى فانا كنت شايف من دراسه الموقف
كله ان في مخالفه واضحه من المستشفى وتعنت
ليه طبعا عشان كده انا دخلته والحمد لله
ربنا يوفقني وهمم وخرجناها والمفروض ان
احنا كنا هنروح ناخذها ثاني يوم بس همم
طبعا الزومبا لو الاستاذ ياسر الاستاذ
حسام حبيب راح اخذوها قبل ميعادنا مثلا
بساعتين ثلاثه
طيب في هذه الحاله استاذ مصطفى
على حقك الادبي والماده من الطرف الاخر
بعد كل ما حصل بعد خبر رجوع شيرين الى
حسام حبيب
والله
ربنا يا رب ما يجيبش حاجه وحشه لاي بني
ادم وهي فنانه طبعا تستاهل مننا ان احنا
ندعي لها ان انا ربنا
يعينها وربنا يوفقها على قرار الصح يعني
بس طبعا انا كنت طلعت قبل كده في مداخله
مع
الاستاذ الاعلامي الكبير تامر امين
الحياه الادب بتاعي انا اخذته بنشر
الفيديو طبعا اا استاذ تامر كان تكلم في
الحته دي والناس
الداخليه
ثاني بالذات ان هم دلوقت متجاهلين وهمم
وما فيش احد طبعا حاول التواصل ليا رغم
ظهور الاعلامي فطبعا انا اعتقد
الايام الجايه اجراءات القرانيه طبعا
للحصول الادبي والمادي طب حسب المعلومات
التي نشرت مؤخرا عن ازمه شيرين تم اجبارها
على دخول المستشفى من الناحيه القانونيه
هل يجوز ذلك
قانون عندنا اللي بينظم دخول قانون الصحه
النفسيه 71 لسنه
91 2009
في دخول ايرادي ودخول الزلزاني الدخول
الالزامي طبعا بيبقى خاضع لان اللي بيعمل
الاجراء ده طبيب نفسي بناء على ظهور في
الحاله النفسيه للمريض لو في تهديد له
الصحه العامه وصحه وصحه الاخرين او نتدهور
في حالته الصحيه طبعا الكلام ده وبيرفع
المنشئه بترفع تقرير في خلال 24 ساعه من
دخول المريض للمجلس الاقليمي للسياحه
النفسيه للبث في استمرار وجودها او عدم
استدعاء وجودها في المستشفى للتلقي
العلماء طبعا الكلام ده في حالات الفنانه
هنطبقه عليها هو طبعا ما ما ما تعملش
الاجراءات دي والاجراءات كلها يعتبر يعني
همم فيها بطلان
وطبعا الاستاذ ياسر بقى هو اللي متكافل
الموضوع ده
والله يا فندم بصي حضرتك انا يمكن لما
ظهرت في مع الاستاذ تامر امين وبيقول لي
حته الخروج اللي هو ان هي خرجت مع الاستاذ
قلت له والله انا اشك في الكلام ده لان
اللي انا شفته والاستعانوا بيا طبعا هو
الاستاذ حسام حبيب واستاذ حسام الشيخ كان
هو اللي موجود في ال- اا يعني قبل طبعا
تواجد بايام وموجود في النيابه في نفس
اليوم عشان همم يقول بقى قال عشان يخرجها
وهو اكثر واحد كان صاحب المصلحه وهمم اكيد
هم كانوا على تواصل بكده وهو طبعا يعني
اكيد كان منتظرها عشان الخطوه اللي هم
عملوها دي يعني كل الموضوع ده كان مرتب
وهمم واضح وكان موجود بس طبعا هو ما كانش
ظاهر على الساحه عشان كان السوشيال ميديا
والاعلام كان عامل دقه في الموضوع ده يعني
شكرا جزيلا يعني من القاهره